it's great to have back on the program
once again Anand girdardas who is a
journalist and commentator the new book
is the persuaders at the front lines of
the fight for hearts minds and democracy
really appreciate having you back on
well thank you for having me back so
intuitively I have the sense that on
political issues it is now more
difficult to persuade people even when
the facts are on one side and I think
maybe the first place to start is it is
that perception accurate is it true that
there we are in an era where political
beliefs are in a sense more like sticky
or stubborn or difficult to change yeah
well I think another way to think about
that is is the is the fraction of people
who are very difficult to persuade has
that fraction of people grown I think
that's in a way what we mean when we
talk about polarization
right that that the country has sorted
into uh these kind of two political
tribes
um but I think part of where the
persuaders book starts is from the
premise that we have confused
polarization for meaning that no one is
persuadable anymore which is not true it
is the case that significant minorities
of people on each side are not
persuadable and what defines that group
on each side and the left and the right
is not how strong their opinions are but
how deeply held those strong opinions
are which is to say you can imagine
someone we all know this person who will
huff and puff about a strong border
right
but you could imagine someone who Huffs
and puffs about a strong border who has
watched
80 documentaries about immigration
policy and reads books about it and goes
to you know militiamen meetups where
they talk about the border that is not a
persuadable voter that is someone who
not only has a strong opinion but has a
strongly held strong opinion you know
that person has talking points to rebut
any objection you might make that person
you know and that exists on the left
also there's people who you know have a
strong stance on Universal Health Care
because they've really they thought of
it's part of a world view they've
thought about it they've bolstered it
it's part of their Community uh
consciousness
but then there are other people who vote
alongside
the strong border guy or the Universal
Health Care person
who may have that opinion on the surface
but have much shallower roots of that
opinion they haven't watched a bunch of
documentaries about border policy they
have not
read a bunch of books they have what in
I think the corporate world is sometimes
called strong opinions lightly held
right and persuadable voters are people
who might have strong opinions but also
have them lightly held they are as a
notchenkarosoria one of the many
brilliant persuaders I write about in
the book says these persuadable voters
are people who can be toggled into a
very Progressive way of looking at the
world or a very conservative way of
looking at the world to give you an
example on immigration
when the thing in the air
is imagery of people crossing migrants
crossing the border in Caravans
those persuadable people can be toggled
into with the right messages can be
toggled into a very right-wing
nationalist fear-based close the border
as you will remember a couple years ago
when
family separation
was the dominant thing we were all
seeing on the news every day
a lot of those same moderate persuadable
voters where if you remember using the
phrase This Is Not Who We Are
right those same people who want a
different circumstance might have been
toggled into a very right-wing
understanding of the Border where in
that moment with that set of fact that
set of stimuli toggled into a very
Progressive understanding of the
question and so this book is about how
you speak to those significant numbers
of people in the middle who you don't
need most of them you don't need all of
them
but if you can win many of them in a
given moment in a given election on a
given question it can make the
difference between very different
futures
when people often will call in and ask
about persuasion
whether it's at a dinner table or
whether it's in a national election
oftentimes the conversation is different
and we've talked with people who
specialize in kind of changing beliefs
at what we might call the retail level
which is you build a relationship with
someone that you personally know and
there's often many conversations and
here's the average number of hours that
it can take and that that's sort of like
one bucket the other bucket is widely
held beliefs
for large numbers of people for the
purposes of winning an election and how
views can be shifted in those sort of
situations can you talk a little bit
about with that second group which is
for the purposes of winning an election
with views that might include Trump was
actually the winner in 2020 it was
stolen from him or you know Democrats
want to do abortions when a baby is
already six months out of the whatever
the case may be what are the techniques
that can be used in those sorts of
situations well
the last the the actual examples you
raised are in a way not examples of
arguments but examples of disinformation
right so there's a chapter in the book
that is about persuasion in the context
of disinformation which in some ways is
a separate uh separate question from
traditional you know traditional
political persuasion so and and just to
be clear it's different why because it's
simply based on a misunderstanding of a
fact rather than maybe conflicting
morals or something like that exactly
like if you and I are having an argument
about whether
you know uh a fetus is a
person deserving of legal status and
protection from homicide laws or not
yeah
that's not an issue of you and I having
different
facts or senses of reality like the
facts are broadly agreed it's a you know
whether a fetus is a person deserving
that protection is a moral argument that
depends on you know interpretation and
that and a lot of politics you know or
or just like is a 31 marginal top tax
rate or a 39 percent one going to
enhance economic growth and broadly
shared Prosperity again no one is we're
not you know in hopefully in a good
version of that conversation we're
looking at a common set of facts and
historical data and we're inter these
things are complicated right yeah the
examples you cited really are where we
are now in many cases where it's like
moon is made of green cheese territory
and you know the world is run by a
global pedophile ring run out of a pizza
restaurant on Connecticut Avenue in
Washington DC kind of thing with Q Anon
43 million Americans by the way now
believe in the underlying fantasies of Q
Anon which means 43 million Americans
could be understood to be in a diffuse
dispersed you know uh virtual cult yeah
um so the issue you raise is very
important and
I I spoke to two different experts for
that chapter about what we do about this
problem how do you persuade in the
context of people having really their
own sense of reality that is non-reality
and the tooth you know one of them was a
cult deprogrammer a former cult victim
herself who got out of the cult and then
helps other people get out of Cults uh
one at a time right and she's now
thinking about what are you doing
millions of people are being manipulated
in cult-like ways by leaders like Donald
Trump or disinformation
um and then I spoke to a cognitive
scientist who works a lot on uh covid
and I mean uh climate and then now covet
disinformation and try to figure out how
do you deal with that and what both of
them said from their different Vantage
points that really surprised me was that
essentially we may need to treat
disinformation as endemic in the age of
the internet that there's not going to
be a I mean literally a disinformation
artist owns Twitter right now so the
idea of the idea of shutting off this
spigot feels I think to both of them a
little fanciful and what they suggest
sticking with the kind of Public Health
endemic analogy if this is endemic if
this information is going to be in the
air
the answer is to inoculate people
against it don't worry this is not like
a an actual shot right but a public
health approach to disinformation is
what they suggest which is essentially
an educational
uh an educational shift where basically
the way you know things like sex ed were
once taught to people in their homes if
at all or people figured it out behind
the barn or whatever now you know sex ed
came to be thought of as something that
was crucial to any child's development
we the the state the society has an
obligation to have everybody have a
common minimum understanding of their
own bodies and sexuality and where
babies come from and and so on and so
forth well I think being able to detect
and kind of interdict these common
tactics of cult manipulation and
disinformation
may become viewed as a core part of an
education today you know critical
thinking is what like here's a passage
of a book you know uh what are the three
main ideas and which ones that that's
not no no no that's quite lacking that
definition of critical thinking was you
know not adequate I think to you know 15
year olds being up against Rupert
Murdoch and we need to fortify them and
to detect
how and when they are being conned
because you mentioned Cults and we've
we've also interviewed experts on Cults
and getting people out of Cults former
cult members Etc
obviously the inoculation ahead of time
preventing people from getting sucked in
in the first place absolutely a great
thing important thing reality is a lot
of people are already sucked in what
methods of persuasion have you seen be
most effective at getting someone out of
a cult so the in the interesting thing
here that I learned again from both
Diane Ben scotter and the and uh John
Cook the scientist is that what we are
10 what we tend to do instinctually when
we encounter those people is ass
backwards uh almost designed to not work
and drive them further into the arms of
the Khan what we often do is make them
feel stupid uh we often uh try to rebut
their points Point by Point haggle on
reality present data a lot of us are you
know on the other side in the
reality-based community are like
interested in data and evidence and we
kind of lead with that
and we don't understand what's
necessarily going on there and so what
both Diane and John educated me on is
basically they view a someone who has
been who has succumbed already as you
say
uh as someone who there's kind of two
warring forces within them that person
and one of them has is badly beating the
other the first Force
is the desire to have the world make
facile sense
we all have that desire every single one
of us has that desire yep
Cults and disinformation prey on that
desire right the world is complicated
globalization is complicated covet is
complicated Q Anon comes in it's
actually very simple right it's
appealing and it hooks certain people
the second desire that is also in every
human heart is the desire to be no one's
fool the desire to be no one's dupe the
desire not to be a mark for the for
powerful manipulative people
and what has happened in people who've
succumbed to disinformation is that
Force number one has really outgunned
Force number two in them Force number
two is kind of lying latent and so the
thing that works is not factual rebuttal
or evidence or making them feel dumb but
helping them see that they may be being
used
by powerful people who are
manipulating them for the benefit of
those powerful people and not their
benefit helping them see the ways in
which they've been tricked to be clear
this is not going to work all the time
it may not work most of the time yeah
but it has shown some results Diane
benskota wrote about her own experience
being in the Moonies and you know these
these deep programmers came and tried to
her mother organized it tried to come
and get her out and they were telling
her the beliefs about Christ are not
true here's the truth about this here's
the truth none of it worked what worked
on her she was sitting in this room
and they start telling her about
brainwashing techniques in Mao's
revolutionary China
and what was interesting is she didn't
have
emotional defense mechanisms around
Mao's revolutionary China right right it
was not coming at her straight
it was like exotic a world away right
and so maybe she listened a little more
easily than she might have if it had
been straight up here's why what you're
saying about Jesus is not true
and she started hearing the list of
Mao's brainwashing techniques
and she just recognized them
she just and she started she just kind
of described I think the world like
crashing pieces of glass all around her
as a sensation she felt just and and she
kept muttering herself like what if this
was all a lie and so again I don't want
to unders I don't want to overstate how
easy this is right it doesn't always go
that well yeah but but that I think
that's the dynamic you are aiming for
planting a seed of doubt and I would say
lastly this comes up again and again in
the book not just on disinformation
persuasion often involves trying to
displace what is in people's heads not
trying to replace what is in others
heads and certainly not being perceived
as having an agenda of replacing what is
in their heads simply trying to displace
to make people have questions again so
this place rather than replace makes me
want to talk about the group of
canvassers you spoke to in Arizona and
how they were focused on changing
people's minds on on immigration what
were they doing
this was a you know of all the of all
the different
people I studied and you know uh tried
the different types of persuaders I
wrote about from the scientists
Educators to activists to organizers uh
these canvassers in
Arizona filled me with so much hope they
were engaged in this experiment called
Deep canvassing that grew out of the
stinging defeat of gay marriage in
California in 2008 on the night that
Barack Obama got elected right so and
otherwise an otherwise kind of Glorious
night in American history that was you
know that overshadowed this really awful
defeat
by referendum in California in other
words most people's Neighbors
were against
the view of gay people as full human
beings right that was a they didn't know
that they didn't know that that was the
majority view the vote lost L.A County
right gay marriage lost LA County
uh you know what we would think of as a
reasonably decent place to be gay in the
United States gay marriage lost LA
county in 2008 and so these gay rights
activists in the LA LGBT Center and
others were just in a funk and you know
one of them described walking around the
grocery store and you're like standing
in the produce aisle being like
like does this person next to me want to
exterminate me like does this person
think I'm not a person like who you know
it's not Mitch McConnell in like 2 000
miles away it's not people in the
Central Valley like I am surrounded by
people who do not think I'm a human
being
and it you know again this is not for
the faint of heart and it's not for most
people but a certain subset of these gay
activists in
La in that time we're like I want to go
to knock on people's doors and find out
why they hate me
again you may be listening to this
thinking who the hell would want to do
that yeah right and like totally great
to stay at home and not do that but
these people wanted to go do that they
wanted to know they actually had
questions right they didn't they
couldn't understand why people couldn't
understand them and so they went and it
what started kind of informally Helter
Skelter talking to people listening
has since developed into a method that
is remarkable that I witnessed at its
kind of you know maturity in in Arizona
where these canvisters go door-to-door
they don't do 30 second conversations
about have you found your polling place
or do you have a flyer they spend 30 to
40 minutes lovingly patiently
strategically talking people through
their views their deepest prejudices as
well as values that might conflict with
their prejudices they don't they again
displace not replace they don't come in
there and say well you say this about
immigrants being lazy but do you know in
fact David that 25 of immigrants work
900 hours
right what they look for is so you said
immigrants are lazy do you know any
immigrants personally oh well yes my
Gardener Manuel is is Manuel is Manuel
lazy
I know manual works like harder than
most people I know and is is he the only
one in his family was like that or No
actually they're his kids are so hard
working there like in college but
they're also working two jobs
and at some point you just say to them
how is the thing you said at the
beginning sitting with you as you now
tell me about
Manuel and you just let it you create
the great little silence there for them
yeah and people
you know this may sound either
believable to you listen if you're
listening to this are not believable but
not everyone has probably thought about
these issues as much as you and I might
have and people listening to a podcast
about these issues might have people
stand there in the door and they're like
it's true a lot of the immigrants I know
are actually the opposite of lazy huh I
wonder why I always go around thinking
they're lazy yeah right that happens
that's real it's true that people will
say a thing about trans people and then
I saw this powerful video of one of
these canvases a black woman uh in
California
talking about her own trans niece and
basically like ragging on her own trans
niece
and then the canvasser is like have you
ever been discriminated against or
treated badly because of things you
couldn't control interestingly as a
black woman in America she did not
connect it to being black she did not
connect to being a woman she connected
it to being like moving from another
city and working in a job in LA and
everyone in her job in La being like you
should you should go back to where you
came from yeah it was just like not from
being around there and she was like that
sucked I just went to work every day and
it just sucked to like I I can't help
that I lived in another city right and
then he's like and how did that feel to
be just seen and treated that way and
and you see this you see it like a wave
crash on This Woman's face like oh
I am to my niece what those people were
to me right you know and so I think this
work of deep canvassing like so much of
the work of persuasion depends on a kind
of faith that many people if not most
can change can move uh think what they
think in part because of what what
they've seen what they have not seen
where they've been where they've not
been and that exposure and conversation
and listening and empathy can get us
there this is not an argument to go
around knocking on dangerous doors and
you know hoping to be respected if
you're a marginalized person this is a a
book about some people who choose to do
this work out of their own volition
because they believe that people can
change
the book is the persuaders at the front
lines of the fight for hearts minds and
democracy we've been speaking with the
book's author Anand girdardas always
great having you on uh and really great
great book very much enjoyed it and
we're going to link to it and encourage
our audience to pick it up well thank
you so much for having me it's good to
be back